merci tu as mis un Metz Walid être avec
nous durant cette demi-heure vous êtes
élu de Mayotte membre du groupe RDP
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes indépendants sur le groupe
des sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle on va bien sûr longuement
parler de la situation à Mayotte dans
quelques instants mais d'abord un mot
sur ce premier mais on l'a vu 2,3
millions de manifestants selon la CGT
782000 selon ministère de l'intérieur on
est quand même moins de l'essoufflement
sur lequel mise le gouvernement c'était
une mobilisation importante il faut le
souligner ce n'était pas une
mobilisation que contre la réforme des
retraites mais c'était le 1er mai la
fête des travailleurs et et du travail
un essoufflement je ne sais pas si c'est
le bon mot mais nous savons qu'il y a
une réforme qui a été votée d'après la
procédure que nous connaissons c'est une
réforme quoi que en dissertant qui a été
voté démocratiquement avec le recours à
l'article 49 3 c'était la cinquième fois
que dans notre pays on avait recours à
cet article pour pour le surplus faut
condamner avec vigueur les violences en
marche de cette mobilisation importante
qui sont le fait de personnes
radicalisées et qui viennent gâcher
cette ce moment cette fête du travail je
veux des violences qui vont aller en
s'accroissant une radicalisation de ce
mouvement je veux rendre hommage aux
forces de l'ordre et notamment aux
policiers aux gendarmes qui ont été
blessés il faut espérer que non que la
situation n'empire pas parce que dans
une démocratie il est important de
débattre de confronter les opinions mais
on ne doit jamais à venir aux violences
telles qu'on le voit ici
sauf que les Français étaient encore
très nombreux dans la rue hier que les
syndicats ne sont pas prêts à tourner la
page de la réforme des retraites
l'exécutif ne pourra pas tourner cette
page aussi rapidement qu'il le souhaite
il y a une même tendue avec un cap clair
qui a été fixé par le président de la
République et une feuille de route qui a
été détaillée par la première ministre
c'est très fort et passée maintenant
nous avons un calendrier un agenda
politique qui donnera l'occasion de
discuter de conditions de travail de la
pénibilité de tous ces sujets là très
importants pour pour les Français et les
Français
à revenir à la table des négociations
Laurent Berger l'a dit d'autres
également sauf que ils ont des
conditions et que ils disent que la
confiance n'est pas là il va falloir
faire des concessions assez syndicats il
va falloir dialoguer
un accord c'est le résultat
effectivement de concessions réciproque
mais certaines
certaines conditions qui sont exigées
comme le retrait de la réforme je ne
pense pas que ça soit une au sujet sur
la sur la loi travail sur le pacte que
vous souhaitez sur le travail sur la loi
pleine emploi vous allez faire des
concessions vous allez devoir faire des
concessions nous l'étions nous étions
près dès la discussion de cette réforme
et si les oppositions c'était plus
accentués sur ce débat sur ses échanges
sur ces concessions plutôt que de
vouloir absolument faire échec à cette
réforme on en serait peut-être pas là on
va parler de l'actualité à Mayotte
beaucoup de sujets mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est cette vaste opération
lancée par le gouvernement pour tenter
d'endiguer l'immigration illégale et la
délinquance pour en parler on va aller à
Mayotte à pas Mandy où on retrouve Bruno
Minas bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous vous êtes journaliste à Mayotte la
première alors d'abord dites nous en
quoi consiste cette opération wambushu
et comment se passe-t-elle sur place
écouter l'opération qu'on appelle one
Bouchu à trois objectifs l'un étant de
d'expulser le plus possible d'étrangers
en situation irrégulière qui représente
une somme considérable dans la
population de Mayotte l'autre objectif
est de détruire les bidons villes qui se
répandent à très grande vitesse à
Mayotte et surtout autour du chef-lieu
du département Mamoudzou mais aussi dans
d'autres communes de Lille et puis le
troisième objectif essayez d'en finir ou
en tout cas de limiter l'insécurité
galopante à Mayotte le nombre de vols
d'agressions alors sur ces trois
objectifs il y en a un qui ça a commencé
depuis une semaine seulement il y en a
un qui semble en bonne voie en tout cas
au regard de ce que l'on voit ici c'est
justement la lutte contre l'insécurité
il y a eu des arrestations notamment
d'un chef de bande qui était recherché
depuis longtemps donc il y a un espoir
de ce côté-là en revanche sur les autres
objectifs un bidonville on est en France
ici à Mayotte ça ne se rase pas comme ça
d'un coup de Bull faire il y a des
recours en justice et on sait que lors
de la première destruction prévue le
tribunal a refusé au préfet
l'autorisation donc de détruire cette
habitat insalubre il y a d'autres
procédures en cours mais on sait que ça
va être compliqué et beaucoup plus long
qu'on ne l'a dit et ensuite s'agissant
des reconduites à la frontière alors là
on bute sur un véritable problème c'est
que les Comores ne veulent pas récupérer
leur
ressortissants ils ne veulent pas des
reconduites à la frontière donc pour le
moment c'est bloqué et c'est même pire
que ça puisque on a appris que des quoi
ça vous savez ces bateaux fragiles qui
amènent les immigrés depuis l'île
d'Anjouan jusqu'à l'île de Mayotte les
quoi ça continue d'arriver il y en a eu
deux intercepter mais on ne sait pas
combien sont passés et donc du fait de
la non reconduction un effet de les de
l'opération risque d'être fait contraire
à savoir l'augmentation du nombre
d'étrangers en situation irrégulières en
tout cas on en est là pour le moment ça
fait une semaine que cette opération a
commencé elle est largement soutenue par
la population française qui représente
que la moitié des habitants de Mayotte
et par la population étrangère intégrée
qui qui dispose de titres de séjour mais
pour l'instant les effets de cette
opération ne sont pas visibles encore et
Bruno vous avez une question pour le
sénateur oui j'ai une question monsieur
le sénateur bonjour Je
je comprends pas très bien pourquoi on
n'a pas associé à embushu un dispositif
de non retour des étrangers en situation
régulière c'est à dire qu'on parle
beaucoup d'expulsion
de contrôle mais en revanche on a rien
dit sur comment empêcher ces bateaux de
revenir parce que le problème est là à
Mayotte en expulse énormément 80
personnes par jour et ces gens-là
reviennent pratiquement le lendemain le
sur le lendemain la semaine suivante et
on a l'impression que rien n'a été fait
de ce côté là
oui bonjour monsieur Minas
le empêcher l'équation de venir voilà
effectivement un point essentiel et ce
n'est pas parce que on en a pas parlé
officiellement que il ne faut pas
développer ce point ce point très
important
en tous les cas aujourd'hui face à ce
blocage partiel les élus de Mayotte qui
sont à l'origine de cette opération en
tout cas qui que nous avons demandé avec
avec force nous demandons au
gouvernement de déployer les les bateaux
qu'il faut les intercepteurs qu'il faut
au large de Mayotte pour dissuader c'est
quoi ça quoi ça à devenir à défaut pour
l'instant de pouvoir ramener les
personnes en situation étrangère
en tout cas la situation impose que ce
dispositif soit soit augmenté c'est fait
en place
d'interception aujourd'hui dans la
mesure où il y a de quoi ça qui arrive
encore à Mayotte c'est quelque chose qui
me faudrait absolument éviter et
renforcer cette partie du dispositif y
compris en faisant appel à l'armée
au bateau militaire bien évidemment
cette opération ou un bouchon elle a une
réelle efficacité où est-ce que c'est un
coup de communication il faut attendre
la fin d'une opération pour se demander
si elle a été efficace ou pas en tout
cas cette opération est nécessaire parce
que les objectifs rappelés tout à
l'heure par Monsieur Minas il devrait
mettre tout le monde d'accord lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine lutter
contre l'insécurité qui gangrène les les
Mahorais et détruire ces bidonvilles qui
sont de vrais repères à personne en
situation irrégulière à criminelle à
délinquant
parce que l'objectif de Gérald Darmanin
c'est détruire un millier de bidonvilles
en deux mois c'est faisable
ce sont des procédures qui sont qui ne
sont pas faits comme ça comme cela a été
rappelé nous sommes en France c'est dans
le respect d'une procédure très
particulière qui a été insérée dans la
loi Elan et procédure qui a commencé à
être mis en place à partir de 2018 et en
amont ce sont des mers qui ont demandé
que dans leur commune telle bidonville
tel to guide doivent être doivent être
détruits en deux mois le temps de ce
début de l'opération on ne peut pas
raisonnablement demander à ce que tous
les bidonvilles de Mayotte soient rasés
mais c'est un coût d'accélérateur et la
destruction de ces bidonville doit
continuer y compris lorsque cette
opération aura connu une fée une fin
comme c'est destructions ont commencé
avant cette opération pour vous la
destruction de ces bidonvilles ça peut
permettre de faire baisser la
délinquance sur l'île
bien sûr non seulement faire baisser la
délinquance mais ce sont des bidonvilles
qui sont extrêmement dangereux moi
aujourd'hui je m'étonne énormément de
ces associations de ces organisations
qui font tout pour empêcher la
destruction de ces bidonville pas plus
tard qu'avant-hier une jeune gamine de
deux ans
aujourd'hui et entre la vie et la mort
j'espère qu'elle sera sauvée parce que
de l'électricité qui alimentait un
taudis de façon illégale a fait que le
feu a pris et il y a eu cet accident en
2018 je le rappelle une mère et ses
quatre enfants a été tué dans une coulée
debout intervenu dans dans ce genre de
bidonville donc aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que l'on veut est-ce que l'on cherche à
ce qu'il y ait cette insécurité dans ces
bidonville qui persiste il faut
absolument commencer par ça les
éradiquer parce que en plus d'être des
lieux d'insécurité effectivement c'est
dans ce bidonville que se retranche
souvent les délinquants et les criminels
et après la destruction de de ces
bidonvilles la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine ne se limite
pas à cela non seulement ces trois
objectifs doivent être continué mais la
lutte contre l'immigration clandestine
et protéiforme et doit continuer après
cette opération Bruno vous avez une
autre question
oui en fait on s'étonne de voir cette
opération purement sécuritaire en tout
cas pour le moment ne pas être
accompagné de quelque chose qui donne de
l'espoir parce que vous avez ici des
gens qui viennent survivre qui vont
travailler pour 200 euros par mois parce
que Comores il ne pourrait en gagner que
5 ans qui vivent dans des conditions
épouvantables et il n'y a pas de plan on
ne parle pas en tout cas de plan de
développement de maillot de Mayotte
c'est une île qui pourra se dire de
produits rien n'exporte rien le tourisme
est quasiment inexistant l'agriculture
est à peine
balbutiante la pêche l'aquaculture il y
a énormément de projets sur lesquels on
pourrait donner de l'espoir aux gens en
tout cas aux gens de Mayotte et à ceux
qui viennent ils travaillaient en
situation régulière et là on parle
uniquement de destruction de bidonville
de renvoyer des gens qui n'auront aucun
souci c'est de revenir
l'espoir Bruno Minas
en direction des Comoriens c'est au
président azali de donner de l'espoir
pour ses concitoyens nous nous sommes
des élus de Mayotte nous passons d'abord
à la population mahoraise aux françaises
et aux Français de Mayotte et aux
personnes en situation régulière il faut
poser cette question au président azali
qui a été suffisamment influent pour se
faire désigner président de l'Union
africaine et qui aujourd'hui est
incapable de s'occuper de sa de sa
population il y a de l'espoir il y a il
y a de l'espoir je je m'inscris un faux
dans cette dans cette opération parce
que on ne va pas détruire des
bidonvilles pour le plaisir de les
détruire ensuite nous allons construire
des écoles des logements sociaux nous
allons construire des infrastructures
mais pas pour les personnes en situation
irrégulière pour les Français et pour
les personnes en situation régulière ça
c'est ça le l'espoir pour le reste si on
ne commence pas par ça et bien dans 10
ans dans 50 ans dans 100 ans on sera
encore en train de débattre pour savoir
par quel bout il faut commencer c'est
par là qu'il faut commencer et c'est ça
le début de l'espoir et moi je suis
désolé je veux bien faire preuve
d'humanité mais ma préoccupation c'est
d'abord les citoyens de Mayotte comment
vous faites et que peut faire la France
avec les Comores qui refusent de
reprendre les expulsés ce n'est pas
force d'avoir essayé d'abord ce qui
sépare cette suspension actuelle des
reconduites à la frontière par rapport
au passé parce que ce n'est pas la
première c'est qu'il y a eu un accord de
2019 signé entre les présidents français
et Comoriens et aujourd'hui moi je ne
comprends pas je ne comprends pas que un
président de l'Union africaine qui est
enquête de respectabilité et bien
choisissent de ne pas respecter cet
accord qu'il a pourtant signé et cet
accord disait très simplement et très
clairement que
les les Comores s'engager à lutter
contre les trafics humains très
clairement à à tout faire pour que
l'équation
s'arrêtent au départ des Comores et à
lutter contre l'immigration clandestine
et en contrepartie l'aide de la France
était conséquente 150 millions en 3 ans
et justement c'était une de
développement vous le dites de 150
millions sur 3 ans est-ce qu'il faut
suspendre cette aide au développement il
faut commencer par ça il faut commencer
par ça dans dans un accord lorsque l'une
des parties ne respecte pas cet accord
la première chose à faire c'est d'un
suspendre la contrepartie et de
d'insister et
de monter crescendo en étant ferme pour
que cet accord soit respecté donc il
faut suspendre l'aide immédiatement pour
vous bien évidemment
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres moyens euh de
faire pression est-ce que par exemple il
faut geler les avoir des Comoriens
Mayotte est-ce qu'il faut geler les
visas votre collègue député Estelle
Youssoupha dit que la moitié du
gouvernement comorien un passeport
français est-ce qu'il faut agir
là-dessus je ne sais pas si c'est si
c'est la moitié mais bien sûr il faut en
venir à ces mesures de fermeté vous
savez
l'intransigence de pouvoir comorien
pousse à l'extrémité aux extrêmes faut
pas inverser les choses
c'est un transigence qui nous pousse
sans cesse à aller chercher des
solutions qui au départ n'étaient pas
pensé mais dispositions sur le code de
la nationalité et bien c'est parce que
cette situation on n'en voit pas le bout
et en face nous n'avons que de
l'intransigence donc le gouvernement la
France n'est pas assez fermé avec les
Comores le gouvernement doit être plus
ferme face à la situation et à
l'intransigence de pouvoir comorien
Bruno question
oui quand je parlais tout à l'heure de
développement je parlais pas de
développement des commandes mais deux
Mayotte c'est à dire que par exemple
lorsqu'il y a eu un grand mouvement
contre l'incurité en 2018 il y a pas si
longtemps on avait promis à la suite de
ce mouvement une dette exceptionnelle à
Mayotte à des investissements à hauteur
d'un milliards et demi d'euros
comment voulez-vous penser à du
développement lorsque les personnes se
font massacrer se font agresser tous les
jours comment voulez-vous penser à du
développement si il y a une situation
insécuritaire telle que même se rendre
chez soi le soir les gens les gens ont
peur ce n'est pas possible dans l'état
actuel des choses et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut remettre les choses dans l'ordre
avant de penser au développement arrêter
d'inverser les choses
merci Bruno Minas merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous et merci à Mayotte la
première d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
justement on va parler de ce contexte
social de ce contexte sécuritaire à
Mayotte tout de suite avec Alex tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Tani Mohamed suali
montrent bien que Mayotte est dans une
situation critique effectivement
notamment du point de vue de la pauvreté
77% des habitants de Mayotte vivent sous
le seuil de pauvreté le PIB par habitant
et 4 fois inférieur à celui de la
métropole et le département connaît
cette année un taux de chômage qui se
situe à 30% c'est le record national
malheureusement et c'est le record cette
année à Mayotte depuis 2009 en termes de
santé et bien les infrastructures ne
sont pas non plus au rendez-vous 50% des
habitants affirment avoir déjà du
renoncé à un soin médical faute d'offres
de santé suffisante on le disait Mayotte
est également en territoire touché par
la délinquance et l'insécurité les vols
avec armes ont augmenté l'an dernier de
121% par exemple sur la période
2018-2019 il y a eu trois fois plus de
vols à Mayotte qu'en métropole et selon
l'Insee la moitié des habitants à
Mayotte se sente en
sécurité et d'ailleurs certains
habitants qui s’estiment délaissés par
les pouvoirs publics et bien forme des
collectifs citoyens de lutte contre la
délinquance ils organisent des
patrouilles dans les quartiers dans les
bidonvilles parfois au périls de leur
vie on va voir un extrait du
documentaire réalisé par notre
journaliste Jérôme Rabier cet hiver à
Mayotte sur ce point on nous appelle
comme quoi les voisins étaient
cambriolés et il y a eu des ordinateurs
qui ont été volés des des portables des
tablettes et donc on est parti les
chercher on a trouvé certains éléments
sur la par terre et donc ça nous
encouragé à suivre à chercher et à un
moment donné on est arrivé ici
même c'est juste en bas là
on est tombé vraiment c'était là nez
année avec deux individus qu'on le
connaissait forcément pas on n'a jamais
vu les visages et donc moi je me
retrouve à un moment là avec lui
j'essaie de le rattraper de l'attraper
comme ça et en fait il avait une
machette que j'avais pas vu et il me l'a
asséné ici même
sans sommation ni quoi que ce soit
à l'époque c'était le c'était
c'était le début en fait de cette
violence à outrance et moi j'imaginais
pas jusque là jusque que on pouvait
comme ça consciemment donner un coup de
machette sur quelqu'un voilà essayer des
inconvénients sont le plus souvent de
jeunes Comoriens en situation
irrégulière une question sur la sécurité
une question sur la sécurité sur
l'insécurité quand vous voyez c'est
collectif de citoyens qui risquent leur
vie pour essayer et bien d'améliorer la
situation ils le disent ils se sentent
délaissé par les forces de l'ordre
est-ce que c'est le cas
c'est de plus en plus le cas
vous savez votre collègue Jérôme Rabier
elle est sur place et et à ressenti les
choses et moi j'en profite pour vraiment
faire un appel solennel à ses
organisations assez syndicale notamment
le Syndicat de la magistrature qui
loin derrière leur fauteuil ici sont en
train en fait dans d'empirer les choses
indirectement par par leur action les
Maoris vivent une situation mais quand
vous quand vous avez un syndicat de la
magistrature avant l'opération qui
envoie un communiqué de presse pour et
d'aimer aux membres de du Syndicat de la
magistrature pour dire c'est une
opération de com c'est
une manœuvre du gouvernement et quelque
part ne pas appliquer la loi et dire
qu'il ne faut pas faire d'amalgame entre
insécurité et immigration moi l'amalgame
de façon générale je ne je ne le fais
pas mais à Mayotte ce n'est pas de
l'amalgame à Mayotte c'est une réalité
et que vous voyez que aujourd'hui ce
sont les membres de ces syndicats qui
rentrent les décisions mais comment les
mahorrer doivent réagir face à ça donc
effectivement il y a de plus en plus de
personnes qui disent mais puisque
personne ne s'occupe de nous nous allons
nous organiser malheureusement il y en a
qui ont fait ça dans dans l'illégalité
et ce sont vu traduire devant la justice
et le maorisent mais en fait la justice
est contre nous
ce matin informations à vérifier
j'apprends que le délinquant l'un des
chefs de banque qui a été arrêté
avant-hier serait relâchés j'espère
vraiment que cette information n'est pas
n'est pas vraie parce que ça serait un
envoi un signal catastrophique envoyée à
Mayotte moi j'ai toujours eu le plus
grand respect pour la séparation entre
l'autorité judiciaire le pouvoir
judiciaire comme on le dit et le pouvoir
législatif mais à un moment il faut
arrêter de jeter de lui sur le feu dans
ce département et moi j'estime que
certaines ONG et le Syndicat de la
magistrature jette de l'huile sur le feu
à Mayotte
un mois Alex sur les chiffres de
l'immigration puisque Mayotte vous le
disiez en sublime immigration
incontrôlable et il doit faire face à un
défi démocratique effectivement un défi
démographique Mayotte c'est le
département le plus jeune de France 23
ans de moyenne d'âge et ce territoire
connaît une véritable explosion
démographique en un peu plus de 50 ans
et bien la population a doublé a été
multipliée par 12 en 20 ans la
population a doublé elle est aux
alentours aujourd'hui de 310000
habitants mais ça c'est le chiffre
officiel avec et bien toute cette
population étrangère en situation
irrégulière et bien la population est
peut-être même
et peut-être au niveau au niveau du
double de 600 700 000 habitants il y a
effectivement une pression migratoire la
moitié de la population à Mayotte et
étrangère elle vient de ses îles des
Comores voisines et parmi ces Comoriens
et bien un tiers est né sur le sol
Mahorais tany Mohamed swahili une
question justement sur ce droit du sol
vous avez participé à ça modification
des lois précédentes en modification à
Mayotte dans la prochaine loi
immigration qui a été annoncée et puis
reportée par le gouvernement est-ce
qu'il faut aller encore plus loin dans
la modification de ce droit du sol à
Mayotte c'est plus précisément
l'adaptation du droit de la nationalité
en fonction de la réalité sur place
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire aller plus
loin
une loi surtout une loi qui qui modifie
une disposition telle que le code de la
nationalité
on doit d'abord à mesurer l'impact
aujourd'hui quel est l'impact de cette
loi il y a un impact qui est certain
c'est que on arrête enfin de d'octroyer
massivement la nationalité a des enfants
qui ne sont pas intégrés et qui ne sont
pas
intégrés dans la dans la société dans la
société mahoraise
moi j'estime que ces dispositions sont
aujourd'hui suffisamment efficaces
notamment par rapport à ce premier
objectif le Conseil d'État lorsqu'il
avait donné entre guillemets le feu vert
à ces dispositions avait émis deux
conditions notamment il fallait faire
une publicité
à en direction des Comores pour
dissuader les femmes qui voulaient venir
accoucher devenir cette publicité n'a
pas été faite il fallait ensuite lutter
farouchement contre les reconnaissances
de complaisance cette lutte n'a pas lieu
donc faisons d'abord ceci et pour voir
jusqu'où
ces dispositions
lui-même veut aller plus loin que votre
proposition il veut porter le délai à un
an je ne sais pas ce que c'est aller
plus loin pour moi aller plus loin
aller plus loin ça serait déjà respecté
ces conditions qu'avaient été émises par
par le Conseil d'État ensuite s'il faut
augmenter ce délai après avoir mesuré
l'impact
des disposition
si elle est plus loin comme vous le
dites
aboutirez à plus d'efficacité vous en
doutez il faut que qu'on voit d'abord un
fonction de cet impact merci Alex à tout
à l'heure à tout à l'heure et merci
thany Mohamed Sally merci d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous parler de cette
situation à Mayotte dans le club des
territoires dans 20 minutes on reviendra
sur ce 1er mai de nombreux Français dans
les Rumes et des cortèges émaillés de
violence dans plusieurs villes on va y
revenir merci beaucoup d'animaux Ahmed
Fally d'avoir été avec nous et on
accueille notre prochaine invitée